LILI
GET 100 OUT OF THE AND GIRGENSO
THE SKATE STAYS ON THE ICE.
THERE IS NO THIS AYS ON THE ICE
OTHER THAN THE AND
GIRGENSONS WILL GET IT AND
RAANTA MAKES THE SAVE.
THE ACTI
CAROLINA HURRRRAGAINST COLUMBUS
>> BOUNCE IN COMPLIMENTS
OF ABBY SHE NEBRASKA AND
NC STAPUCK.
BACK TO JEFF SKINNER.
SKINNER IN THE HURRICANE ZONE.
AND GETS TION. IMPRESSIVE.
>> SIGNED FROM VANCOUVER AND OF
HINOSTROZA AND ICING AGAINST
BUFFALO.
>> BIG TIMENOT A POSSIBILITY
AND LAYERED IT UP ND 4-1
CAROLINA.
>> STARTS WITH A TIGHT TURN AND
GETTING THE LAST SIX THAT
WE HAVE SEEN FROM LOOK AND MAKE
PULLING AWAY FROM FAST.
SIX MINUTES LEFT IN THE THE
PERIOD.
AND GOALS IN OLOFSSON
FIRST SHORTHANDED IN.
AND TROCHECK.
AND THE TO